okay
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
foreign
[Music]
so
tonight
welcome to the table my name is karen
oh my gosh stephanie
sorry
if i haven't seen you in a while i will
call you out nancy
in the spirit of it's so good to have
you here it feels like family's back um
so welcome to the table this is a place
where you are free to be you
in all your glory and all your mess and
i can attest i am
both right now it's been a week
so i was just so glad to be here tonight
because i feel like
i can be fully myself here
and i can be exhausted i can be happy
i can be conflicted and
grateful and all of that is is welcome
here
i have just a couple of announcements a
ways to get connected here at the table
the first one is happening tonight we're
having our welcome to the table class
that is happening right after the
service tonight if you are interested in
being a member at the table or if you're
interested in just hearing more about
the table's mission and values and how
we came to be a church
then i would encourage you to be a part
of that some of you are have already
rsvp'd thank you for doing that
if you are interested in being a part of
that tonight
you are just now hearing about it or you
didn't get a chance to rsvp it's still
open to you so if you would like to be a
part of that tonight it'll go from
roughly 6 15 until about 7 30ish um
brett our pastor will be leading that
you can just come see brett after the
service and let him know you're
interested in in joining the welcome to
the table class and being a part of that
so
secondly our teen meetup group is going
to be launching
with a new school year comes a new year
with our teen meetup and if you have a
kiddo who's a teenager or even 12 years
old
they're gonna have their fall kickoff
event coming up on labor day so that's
is that actually a week from oh my gosh
it's almost september you guys
labor day is next weekend
and so monday we'll be having our team
meetup group kickoff uh maggie and her
gang are going to be leading that that's
going to be
at the sage creek clubhouse which is in
wiley
we can get you all the information just
come see me
uh if you have any if you have any
questions about that or want to know
both of
my teenagers are a part of it so i'd
love to talk to you about that and
answer any questions you have
and then finally
um some of our favorite favorite people
in the world are holding a conference
this november it's an organization
called centerpiece it's led by sally
gary who's just one of those people that
as soon as you meet her you love her and
you feel like you've known her forever
and you just want to sit in her presence
because she's so
great she's so wonderful
every couple years
the centerpiece organization holds a
conference and it's usually here in the
dallas area this year it's at wilshire
baptist church in dallas and this is for
anybody who is lgbtq
allies parents of lgbtq kids
pastors church leaders it is such a
great conference i was able to join it
virtually due to covid a couple years
ago when they had it last
and it was amazing it was it was so
powerful so good
many of our our table members are part
of that marissa is part of the planning
committee uh don who was here um
yeah he's out in the foyer
don actually led a uh one of the
breakout groups um and spoke and so
and listen to this this is their uh
their theme this year a place at the
table
i mean how can we not go to this thing
so we're giving you lots of advance uh
notice on this it is happening november
3rd through 5th you can find out more
centerpiece it's spelled
p-e-a-c-e
that's how you spell the piece
centerpiece.net
and we have these cards available if you
want to grab one on your way out little
itty bitty table
as soon as you exit this room it's on
your right you can grab a card or just
go to centerpiece.net and that'll get
you information centerpiece also has a
facebook page you can ask me you can ask
marissa dawn
for more information on that we're
hoping to get a big group from the table
to go
it is certain to bless your hearts
all right with all that said how about
if we take some time
[Music]
to center ourselves
in peace
the presence of god
center yourself
in the love of god that never fails
be here now
your to-do list can wait
the week ahead can wait
just take a deep breath
one more time
let's pray
god thank you for your presence
thank you that wherever we find
ourselves tonight you are near you are
with us
you love us
help us to operate from a place of
already being loved already being
accepted
and god i pray that you would speak to
each of us tonight very specifically
help us to trust you at deeper levels
surrender to you
to unburden ourselves before you
to receive the gift of your peace
your hope
your love your mercy your forgiveness
your goodness
that is a firm foundation for us to
stand on
to help us to center on you tonight
jesus
to be grateful
for this place and those around us
and whether you're here in this room or
joining us online
i hope you experience the love of god
here
in jesus name amen
amen if you guys want to go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
caitlyn's going to lead this first song
and uh i just hope that as we worship
together that we would receive the the
music that we're
making um tonight as a gift let it be
something that um opens you up to
the goodness of god let it be something
that engages our creativity and um our
minds and our bodies um and i just
invite y'all into that with us this is
an all play and um we're so glad that
each one of you are here
[Music]
your love is
like radiant diamonds
bursting inside us
[Music]
we cannot
contain
[Music]
your love will
surely come
[Music]
blades and wildfires
singing your name
[Music]
to your design
these
[Music]
your love is
bursting inside us
we cannot
contain
[Music]
singing your name
god
[Music]
across the skies
these hallelujahs
[Music]
sing hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
is
stretch across the skies
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah all right
thank you guys for joining us kids y'all
are dismissed to your classes and we're
gonna keep on rolling here
one
three four
in
[Music]
let's all sing that together
everybody
[Music]
steals my
even in the pain it feels
[Music]
where the spirit of the lord is
i'm
[Music]
there is freedom
i
[Music]
i am
amen where the spirit of the lord is
[Music]
there is freedom
i
am free amen
[Music]
oh
free
at last
[Music]
i am
there is
[Music]
there is freedom
i am free amen
let's just sing in our voices where the
spirit of the lord is there is freedom
i am free amen
one more time
where the spirit of the lord is
there is freedom
i am free
amen
yes god thank you that you are life and
light
you are freedom and peace
and god we want to experience that
together tonight
caitlyn's going to lead us in the
prayers of the people so if you guys
would read along with her and if you're
online leave a comment and we will share
that with the rest of the room
for this city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and for captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
please pray for your teachers and
educators
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
is
it goes beyond
the highest stars
[Music]
and pure
how measured
[Music]
it's yeah
jesus
[Music]
could
of parchment paper
[Music]
train to write the
love of god above
[Music]
from the sky
to sky
oh
[Music]
the same
the love of god
[Music]
jose
god we remember tonight that whatever it
is that we've walked into this space
with whatever we faced
in the days leading up till now
your love is greater
and deeper
and it meets all of our needs
[Music]
your love is better
than the other things that we could turn
to god all of our coping mechanisms fall
short
all of our vices
our left wanting god
but you your love your steady
unconditional love
is the anchor
it is our current
it is the force that we want pulling us
forward
meeting us
when we are at our lowest
and soaring with us on the heights
it is the constant god would we return
to it tonight would we return to you
whatever that looks like for each of us
god as we wander
throughout our days as we fill them with
the busyness
tonight we just pause
we remember those words that we've just
spoken
your love
so rich and pure
immeasurable
and strong
it will endure
forever
would it be the thing that we come home
to would it be the embrace that we give
to the world around us
let it guide us
let it mark our lives as unique and
different
we love you god
and we're grateful
we're grateful for you and the way that
you care for us
[Music]
it's in your name i pray all these
things
amen
thank you guys um if you want to go
ahead and sit and as you do you can turn
to the people around you welcome them
make them feel at home
and then brett will get us started with
the message
well good evening
grace and peace
uh you all doing good
doing well has it been a good week
good good well um my name is brett i'm
the pastor here and um it is so good to
be with all of you and um to welcome all
of you that as always includes those
joining us online um we love y'all lots
you are not forgotten
and uh anyone here tonight who is new um
thank you so much for for being among us
we really long to be
um just a hospitable welcoming people
because that of course is exactly who
jesus was he was um all the things we
just sang about he um
lived that expressed it so so
beautifully and so we seek to be that
same kind of people as we um follow in
his steps so
um we are if you're here tonight this is
a special night because
we have been on a journey
since october of 2021
making our way through the book of first
peter
and
we are completing it this evening go
ahead give yourselves a hand
yes
that's good i'm glad you're not cheering
like too loudly if it was like overly
passionate i'd be like okay
there's a series all right
we're so excited to have it over um
but i i am i'm really um
i am excited to have kind of worked our
way through
an entire book of the bible that's
pretty that's a pretty cool thing um now
if you've been with us then you know
especially if you're here in the early
um parts um
the the context of the book of first
peter is basically um peter is writing
to a an outpost like a group a
scattering of churches
and what we would today call modern-day
turkey back then it was like a far-flung
outpost of the roman empire
and um
the context like they were it was um
well a they were a religious minority um
they were facing some persecution
so um and you'll if you've been with us
to the book you've kind of seen the
moments where he's um basically he can
he knows that there's a certain
temptation for them to um kind of start
letting go of their christian faith and
just kind of go with the flow of culture
um this played out like for them some of
the persecution they were facing was
like social ostracism
because of their faith um job loss
things of that nature so just socially
it was just sort of it was just very
uncomfortable for them to pursue this
this um
christ and to to live their christian
faith so um
i i think the some of the the parallels
like in ways our context is quite
different
in other ways i see it similar um and
the way i see it similar is that it does
take quite a bit of discernment for us
as christians to um kind of know how to
engage culture
and to um walk this line of on the one
hand naming or seeing um certain things
that maybe are good like you go into any
culture and i don't think any culture is
just like you know purely good or evil
you know it's it's always messy and
complicated partly because i think the
spirit of god is working with um
i mean as present to all people and is
working in the world to try to draw us
towards goodness and beauty and truth
and and love so there's always a thing
in cultures you can kind of see little
echoes of god any missionary knows this
like when they go into a culture they
don't just assume like well good thing
i'm bringing god here
like it may be they may be bringing the
specific story of christ but their
assumption is is that through the spirit
right god is present to them so there's
good but that's but we on the other hand
we can't and we'll get more into this we
can't like baptize culture we can't just
say oh this is just it's perfect and it
was similar um i think it was similar
for the early church and it's similar
for us today there's also things um that
maybe aren't so good and so we've gotta
we've gotta kind of discern um
the
what the um the christ-like way is
and so
um with that in mind the the title of my
message tonight is um the unholy roar
and this is um
quite a interesting passage it's at the
very end of the book
chapter 5
verses 8 through 9 and then we'll skip
down to verses 13 and 14. peter writes
be alert
and of sober mind
your enemy the devil prowls around like
a roaring lion looking for someone to
devour
resist him standing firm in the faith
because you know that the family of
believers throughout the world is
undergoing the same kinds of sufferings
she who is in babylon chosen together
with you sends you her greetings so does
my son mark greet one another with a
kiss of love peace to all of you who are
in
christ
and those are the closing words of the
book
now um
he obviously begins with this kind of
interesting image of the devil as like a
roaring lion seeking and he made a vowel
i remember as a kid this kind of scared
me it's like oh my gosh the devil's
going to get me um i think we've there's
been kind of a tendency often in the
church to
kind of interpret this in a very kind of
individualistic way you know where it is
like the devil is going to get you you
know and it kind of becomes a somewhat
um kind of moralistic message in terms
of like so don't you do the marijuana
you know or or whatever the kind of drug
of choice or something that's how the
devil gets people you know and we kind
of go down that road i mean i i don't
know i i don't have um
i'm not going to get into
discussions of mara houchi okay but i i
do think you know um
the devil can i guess work through
drugs or something or okay but what i
want to do tonight is not get lost in
such things i want to kind of zoom out
and take a bigger a bigger picture um
kind of a bigger yeah see it from a
bigger perspective so here's kind of the
way i'm going to frame tonight it's with
um this question
where are the roars of the devil coming
from in our own culture
um our own um kind of day and time
that's that's the question i want to
press into and then kind of following
that will be and how might christian
faith offer um kind of resources offer
um a response um to be able to resist
those roars
so uh
that's that's kind of where we're going
tonight by the way on the resist part
this is kind of ties back in with verse
9 where peter seems to assume there is a
resistance he says
resist him
standing firm in the faith okay so where
are the where are the roars coming from
in other words where is the attack
where's the hostility where's the um
danger where's maybe the temptation
for the church today
um we're just jumping right in number
one christian nationalism
christian nationalism so um there is a
whole movement at sway in the church
where we start to um i think overly
align
the kingdom of god and make it too
synonymous with america
and what can happen is that effectively
um america comes to
um kind of effectively replace the
church
it sort of functions like the new church
the the new people of god um
this is this is this is problematic um i
mean partly not only because it's often
not just like even america at her best
which i think even that would still be
somewhat
problematic um when i think of america
at our best i'm thinking like uh
the uh what was the quote it's on the
statue of liberty um from oh that's
right emma lazarus the uh bringing me
your tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free you know that
would be i guess america her best um
but it's not even aligning just with
that or saying like well that's the
kingdom and that's the gospel and that's
the truth then so we'll get on the board
it's even um
really america at her worst
i'm i'm thinking america at her worst at
a kind of an obsession with
individualism
[Music]
can be very obsessed with like
materialism and kind of a form of greed
her twisted racism
right which we continue and continue to
some would be be haunted by
and there can be this move to
as i kind of hinted at earlier not only
baptize
america and american culture
but but
really a move to almost divinize
her
um and speak in ways where she sort of
becomes like the shining city on a hill
to quote jesus who of course was not
actually talking about america
you know but we start to
you can see how it's like it's kind of
in the imagination you know it's in the
the language and the metaphors and the
and it's it's interesting how it just
kind of i don't know it just starts
coming together you know i mean like in
our brains it's of like okay yeah this
makes sense like god's working among us
and like before you know it we've sort
of crossed this line
and um
this becomes i think very very
problematic um now just to be clear i'm
far from an american hater
i'm not one who thinks like america's
uniquely evil in the world or something
like no just
we're just i think each country is kind
of doing their best and is you know
we're mostly a hot mess but we're just
humans trying to figure it out
you know so um so my point isn't to just
kind of go overboard with just ed i
don't know whatever um
but but
on the other hand we ca we cannot
divinize her and um
maybe it's because i love america this
part isn't in my notes but it's because
i love america that i i won't um give
her
i won't have her replace god i won't
have her replace the church
and i want to ascribe to her some sort
of manifest destiny to uniquely
establish the kingdom of god on
earth
and so um anywhere
christians pastors
you know whether it's sundays or maybe
it's social media preach it family
um
anywhere that that sort of message
anywhere that starts to happen
um
that i think in that moment
not mince and words tonight i think that
is the roar of the devil
um why i mean lots of reasons i think
some of it's
it
um
it it i think it leads to a certain form
of arrogance and pride
as we've been talking about in previous
weeks you know in the same way i think
individuals have an ego i think like
institutions
and cultures can also kind of develop
that collective ego and so i think when
we start going down this road
it starts to inflate
and it gets and we i mean hey if history
is any indication like it um that can
get really really dangerous
so that's first
light and breezy message tonight
all right um
i want to give oh there's there's a line
there's a verse from verse 13. uh this
is peter he says she who is in babylon
chosen together with you sends you her
greetings so does my son mark that
little reference to babylon is kind of
interesting because he's not writing
from babylon
babylon as an empire has been dead and
gone for like 500 years
this was well remember the context he's
writing to a little outpost of what what
empire what what government
who's rome
so he's identifying he's writing likely
from rome
and this is what most scholars agree
this isn't babylon he's there's a way
for him to talk about rome without
saying rome um if you know your bible
you know babylon like that's not that's
not a compliment i'll just put it that
way it's um
it's not a compliment i think this is
where you see peter trying to give them
the resources to say hey be careful
you don't like baptize your own culture
you don't you don't um that in essence
where the kingdom of god is no longer
standing over and above and offering a
prophetic word of critique
right and that's that's where i think um
the church and in the kingdom is at its
best um
all right so that's first uh second
another where else do we see or hear i
should say the roar of the devil well at
the risk of sounding like a total
curmudgeon i'm gonna go with social
media
uh maybe all of you love social media i
don't know um i mean the cat videos are
cute
this i must admit if all you see is cat
videos okay i mean i guess have at
social media um
i s but i do see
more than a touch of the demonic kind of
playing out here with i think it's
manifest kind of differently for like
teens
um versus adults so with um teens
there's really um
the the research is pretty fresh on this
because you mean if you think of it like
smartphones have only really been like
just everywhere in the culture since for
maybe 10 years like 2012 was when they
really i mean before that like you know
the business person had the a blackberry
you know and but the internet was
terrible and you're like using a little
stylist to try to pin you know or
whatever i'm just okay maybe the
blackberry didn't have a stylus but you
know i get like it was just bad um
2012 though this was like a few
iterations of the iphone all of a sudden
it's rolling we got the app store this
also changed things the app store and
then the rise really of um social media
where now we've in assassins we kind of
run a mass experiment like hey what's it
like
if you give teenagers kind of access to
all this
and um let's see how it plays out so the
research is still kind of coming in so
far it seems to be not so great that
would be the short version um
specifically for teen girls um there was
a
book the cotyledon of the american mind
by jonathan height and greg lucanov they
unpack this more
but they they cited this study which is
interesting this is from it was done in
the uk a study of 10 000 teenagers
and yeah we have this image so on the
the kind of y axis that
access that vertical line is the
percentage of teens struggling with
depression
and so you can see the baseline it's
about 10 is where that red line starts
for boys you can see the blue line is
lower um closer like five percent um so
that's just like without any engagement
social media this is where things just
tend to fall but what you can see is the
more teen girls specifically engaged the
more that started just
real quick it just starts going up now
for boys you can see they're a little
more resistant
researchers are still kind of working
through why why is this um
it could be the
boys are doing more video games and such
and you know have their own kind of ways
but regardless you can see even for boys
about about the two hours because i
should say that the x-axis that bottom
line is the time
so the more hours you can see for girls
it's pretty much just like the worse it
gets for boys they're kind of flatline
until about two hours a day and then at
that point
symptoms of depression there's lots of
thoughts on it as to why this is it
could be some of the
fomo kicking in you know you see all the
idealized versions of your friends lives
it could be body image stuff where
they're you know going through all these
images and videos and such of
just you know very idealized images of
what life is of what people should look
like you know we like don't all really
look like instagram models and such it's
just not life um
but i should mention though i mean the
research is still young
um but i i want to just name like hey
let's be let's be aware because what we
do have is an absolute mental health
crisis among teens that's for sure
so researchers are still working through
to what degree does social media at this
point it seems to say the research seems
to say it looks like this is playing a
part um
but it's not everything and so um
this and you're just as a pastor as a
father
i see i see
i think the enemy kind of at work here
and um without trying to like demonize
all of technology or something i want us
to like be you know be aware be be awake
as we'll we'll get to a little bit later
how about adults i think it's different
with adults and the research says it's
different um for us i just say it's
social media it's probably just the junk
food of information
and um
and kind of the way it's playing out is
specifically um politically again if
you're just watching your cat videos
okay that's cool
but um what's happening is that the more
viral um something is the more obviously
shareable it must be and the more
shareable for for it to be shareable
it's got to be really it's gotta grab
you
right otherwise you just keep scrolling
so what grabs you
something that produces either fear
or outrage
i'm something emotionally inflammatory
and
and so what you have is it it seems
there's there's just a growing kind of
polarization um in the culture and i'm
thinking specifically along political
lines you know where every like we're
distant and we're growing more distant
effectively now we can barely even talk
to one another
because
everyone thinks everyone else is an
idiot
that's the roar of the devil
i'm being i'm dead serious you guys know
sometimes i have jokey sermons this
one's not one of those
that that i really do see something
demonic in that where we can't speak to
one another anymore
we don't trust
we're growing apart this is
this is something to tune into
and again it takes discernment because
i'm not offering like super easy answers
here you know we'll get some into our
christian kind of some solutions and
things but um
but this is let's let's be aware
let's be aware all right
third
uh the continued exclusion of lgbtq
people from the church
this is one this one obviously it hits
home for obviously our community but
even just for me personally i think at
some point we all kind of reach our own
breaking points
where we just can't be quiet
anymore and for me it was maybe about
five years ago
i was pastoring at another community
there was
a woman who wanted to be part of the
children's ministry
she was new to faith but
very committed
she
had a background she went to school for
childhood education she hoped to
eventually become a teacher she at this
time was still going to school
and um she we had put out a kind of a
request for like hey we need kids
ministry volunteers as every kid's
ministry every church forever
needs i'm just sort of perpetual so we
said we need volunteers by the way we
could use volunteers so anyone that
wants to um
but we put out this you know kind of
feelers like hey we could use and so she
responded
and um
i had to sit down with her and i met
with her in my office
and i had to explain that um
although i didn't personally
um with the policy but the policy of the
church i was at that time
was that
uh you know lgbtq folks couldn't um
lead and specifically in kids ministry
that that for sure wasn't a thing
um and so i had to explain why she
she couldn't
do that
and
i sat there
she she sat right across from me she
didn't say anything
tears just started streaming down her
face
and
in that moment something in me broke
i just knew in my gut like i am hurting
people
i'm not like trying to hurt people i'm
just trying to
you know be a faithful pastor or try to
do what i'm trying
but i
i knew i was hurting people
and a shepherd
should not hurt their sheep
and so that was for me
um
that was the turning point
where i knew
probably wasn't long for that
that church community
and um
it's been quite a journey
here
five years
from that
conversation in three years coming up
november three years since we started
the table
but god has been good and faithful
and um while we are far from the perfect
community let's just be clear about that
this isn't you know now i've started the
perfect journey no
um
but you know what there but god's doing
a good thing
god's doing a good thing and um
to to
my my friends who are a different sexual
orientation and you're here tonight or
listening online later i want you to
know you're loved you're seen
not just like welcomed here with a
strange glass ceiling functioning you
know no no you're just
here
you know like a human being you know
just welcomed among us
and welcome to fully participate
in the life of the church
um
that's i think i think
it's just like a small way to start
opposing that roar
in our culture
now i could continue
with other things i mean we could go
into racial
injustice we could go to child abuse in
the church even a past you know by
pastor i mean there's like oh my
goodness the devil's roars are legion
um
i think
uh
but i don't want to just offer problems
tonight
this could be a very heavy message
indeed um but i do want to offer some
some solutions and these will be drawn
straight from the book of first peter
what might we do
differently well number one
i think we've got to wake up
we've got to wake up
um you know something i take from that
last story about myself is that you know
this idea of the roaring of the devil i
think one of the another downside to
kind of interpreting it in those kind of
the individualistic way where like the
devil's trying to get me to do a bad
thing it's like we don't sort of
understand how
um evil can start to like use us
you know because then it becomes like
well those bad people out there those
other people well they're just becoming
the roar of the devil
and how terrible
and i'm so glad that us you know
this holy huddle we're different um but
actually like in that moment i feel like
i was like maybe not a roar but like the
whisper of the devil
and
and i think this is why we've kind of
got to wake up
and and start to realize like whoa
um
again if history's any indication this
is
this is not just about the evil out
there
this is about the ways that um
again we demonize
things you know and it's it's the things
that we um kind of put on a pedestal you
know whether it's like the capital s
state or um an institution or policy
even church policy
you know the way that evil starts to
manifest through those things um and i'm
again i'm not trying to say like so
throw it all down there's no ins have no
institutions i don't think that works
either
but
we've just got to be aware we've got to
be awake
in our own context um this is why peter
says verse 8 be alert and of sober mind
in other words wake up
think
um listen to one another pray
speak the truth to one another in love
let's not assume we know it all
this is part of of waking up is is all
of us being teachable and open to what
the holy spirit might be um saying and
whispering to us
second we've got to go deep into your
faith you've got to go deep into your
faith um
one of the reasons i'm not
a
what i could have been there was a for
those of you know my story i almost just
exited the church entirely i just
thought this is
there's a mess i want no part of it you
know
and um i ultimately came back and i
chose not to go the kind of uh i don't
know sort of an easy secular agnosticism
you know like just the kind of vague
like i don't really know i don't know if
there's a god i don't know i just don't
get into spiritual things you know i
kind of almost went that road um but
there was one or a few reasons but one
reason i didn't choose to go that road
and i said you want no
no christ there's something compelling
about christ and the story and the whole
thing
and one of the reasons
was because i as to put it in the
language of this message it seems to me
that that secular humanism doesn't
really have um good resources to resist
the roar of the devil
um and what i mean by secular humanism
is this this idea that we can you know
we just sort of like we'll just live as
though god is not we'll just run society
as though god is not we'll just kind of
we don't need a story to live into or
you know we'll just make it up we'll
just make it up
um i just i don't think that works
because what it's kind of led to at
least in american society is of at the
top of our values
seems to be freedom
which i think is a good value i just
don't think it's necessarily good as
like number one value
because it's basically like you know i'm
free free to do what free to do what i
want
okay you know
great you know i'm fr what's right
whatever i choose
and what's what's hap like what's
missing there
there's no orientation towards love and
goodness
like that's not the top of the hierarchy
so let's just start choosing randomly
and just like well that's just right for
me i guess and it's like oh gosh like we
i think i really do believe we um as
human beings we need a story to live
into
and i think we need god i think we need
an articulation of what love and
goodness is and this is where i look to
christ you know probably not
surprisingly you're in a church i'm a
pastor
um
but when i think of jesus i think of
this is what love looks like in a life
this is what the incarnation of jesus is
it's this is what love um
with flesh on is
and
um and so
i can imagine some pushback to this
being like well christians have had
their chance but they sure haven't
been doing too great uh you just
finished talking about you know um
christian nationalism and exclusion all
these other ways the christians are
failing a fair point my friend
um and this is why i said we've got to
go deep in our faith i think we we've
been playing around in the shallow end
too much
too much shallow wind too much sort of
simplistic
um easy answers that are often um to go
back to our earlier theme more american
than christian only we don't realize it
um so we i think we've got to start
going deep into our faith again deep
into the story
to be oriented again by
um the life the death the resurrection
of jesus christ um
third and finally i'll close with this
we've got to lean into christian
community
lean into christian community about the
only thing i'll say about this is um
i know we kind of as well again as
americans we kind of want to just do our
own thing you know it's like well i'll
just take care of me
me maybe my family
and we'll just do our own thing um
but i really want to encourage you that
life is best done in community
and faith is best expressed
in
um community in with friendship and love
and we just we learn so much about
ourselves um
we
i think really it's like our practical
way to learn to actually love god
is by really getting to know people and
opening up and actually being vulnerable
and honest about what's going on in our
life
um when we start to do that things
change i think i see echoes of this in
the book of first peter
when he writes with the help of silas
verse 12
whom my regard is faithful brother i've
written to you briefly encouraging you
testifying to you this is the true grace
of god stand fast in it verse 13 she who
is in babylon chosen together with you
sends you her greetings so does my son
mark greet one another with a kiss of
love peace to all of you who are in
christ can you hear it in there like all
of the relationships right you've got
like um
silas his faithful brother the scattered
churches of rome mark his son in the
faith greeting one another with a kiss
of love maybe just a hug is fine
um
and
i think you can
well i'll say the way we kind of walk
that out here
is not only kind of being here for
sunday worship but also our meetups
if you're not part of a meetup i highly
encourage you to be part of a meetup
this is basically what we call our small
groups they meet kind of throughout the
week we have some that meet online we
have some that meet in person um but
they're a really powerful way for us to
very tangibly and practically actually
get into relationship with one another
and um
and open up and start to live our
christian faith and be supported
in it so
with that in mind as we come to the
table of the lord tonight
i want us to do it in a posture where
we're remembering
that christ helps us to oppose these
unholy roars
i want us to do it as an act of going
deep into our faith
of recommitting ourselves again to the
crucified and resurrected one
i mean if that isn't counter cultural i
don't know what is
we're committing ourselves again to that
path of great love and we're doing it as
a community
we're doing it together
to share
um
in the body the blood of jesus christ
so um
as you come forward i i hope you can do
it in that that heart posture so we
practice what's called an open table
here
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate in communion you are
free to do that
um you don't have to be i don't know
whatever the little ways churches find
to like say well some people can't come
you know um in the end if you're if
you're hungry for christ and you want to
connect well then um there's no
theological police you can just um
engage with us
so um
let me invite you to the table with this
celtic christian invitation this is the
table
not of the church but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have
little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
you guys are welcome to stand with us
and sing this last song um
as we close out
i just want us to
in in the spirit of those last three
things that brett was saying
wake up go deeper lean into community
i want us to think about the words that
we're singing and this and invite god to
continue to do
that work in us to wake us up to change
us because when he is present
and when we're looking to him there is
that hope that he will do the work
there's that hope that he
is changing he is making us new
he is bringing about life
so let's engage this last song together
as we go is kind of our commitment to
those things
[Music]
i lose my ability
to be afraid when i
see the way you
[Music]
anymore
cause when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
shadows that hang around
i'm finding out just who
i
am
[Music]
my
is
[Music]
shadows
again
[Music]
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
is
and i believe i'll never be the same
[Music]
smile
when i see your face
everything changes
[Music]
again
i'm finding out just who i
am
[Music]
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
this moment
some of us have been going through some
stuff around here
and you know a lot of times it's the
loudest voices whether it's you know
those tapes in our head or people around
you or
just in
the culture those loud voices can really
be tough and
you know the enemy roars but then a lot
of times we think we need to
come back with a roar
and
there's when i'm going through hard
stuff there's a quote that i love that i
just helps me in these times and it's
courage doesn't always roar
sometimes
it's that small whisper at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow
keep showing up you guys
keep showing up
keep doing the the good thing the right
thing the hard thing even when any
everything inside of you wants to avoid
or run away or not show up
in a safe way i want to add that as well
in a safe way
um
thank you so much for being with us um
so much to chew on from the message and
the worship and by the way
eileen
man
that's great um don't forget welcome to
the table class i forgot to mention the
beginning of service there's pizza so if
if you want to go but your stomach was
rumbling we got you covered so there'll
be some pizza and drinks in there please
please join us for that um also don't
forget about the centerpiece conference
those uh cards will be out there at the
table also if you are visiting we would
love to connect with you this week uh
just fill out the card it's right as you
go out the door the little itty-bitty
table to your right there are visitor
carts that say the table and a pen just
write your name and a way to get in
contact with you and drop that in the
wooden box out there
also i'll be in the back if you would
like a hug prayer somebody to talk to
i would love to do that so
as you got out into your week if you
feel comfortable
standing to your feet i'd like to send
you out with a benediction
that i believe is true for each and
every one of you
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
unconditional love and grace and
compassion to everybody you come in
contact with
have a good week be blessed
go to the welcome to the table class and
we hope to see you back here next sunday
good night